what is the glen canyon institute glen
canyon institute is a non-profit
organization
with the mission of restoring a
free-flowing colorado river through glen
canyon and grand canyon
okay um and where are you located right
now
we're based out of salt lake city in
salt lake city okay
um so tell me um
you know what
loaded question first up um tell me
what the problems we're seeing you know
in in
in as in as short of a short of an
answer as you can
what is the major problem we're seeing
in terms of getting water to the people
who need it down the colorado river
well the big problem with the colorado
river is an issue of supply and demand
to put it simply there's just not enough
water in the system
to meet the demands that are put on the
river so
a lot of stakeholders in the colorado
river basin are now taking a very
hard look at um how we're going to
manage the river going forward
a lot of people are rethinking old ideas
old foundations of management
um and kind of opening their minds to
what the realities of this river are
going to look like
what are some of those ideas well
the idea that we've talked about for the
last 20 years
is the idea of moving water out of lake
powell
and storing it in lake mead first we
call it the philmede first proposal
and you know when glen canyon dam was
built it was considered to be one of our
country's greatest environmental
mistakes
glen canyon was the heart and soul of
the colorado river
um as far as its ecosystem a very
significant place to a number of native
american tribes
it was the confluence of a number of
rivers and streams
and it was considered to be as beautiful
as the grand canyon
so um you know glen canyon was this
focal point for american
environmentalism
now we don't have enough water in the
system to keep lake powell and lake mead
full
so what we're saying is if we can't fill
both of these reservoirs not even close
why don't we move that water down to
lake mead and let glen canyon
americans lost national park why don't
we let that come back to life
if we were to just real quick yeah if we
were to completely
move the water out of lake powell into
lake mead today
lake mead would only be 70 full so that
just gives you an
idea of how much water is actually in
these reservoirs right now
so you know one of the things that that
water folks
in you know water folks i mean very
generally you know people when we talk
about
um lake mead and sort of the downfall of
the water issues in vegas there are sort
of two things that people talk about
you know one is the amount of water that
that vegas is actually using
um which i'll ask you about in a second
but two
is the advent of the dam and lake powell
and um you know though lake mead hit
records in the 80s
um after uh lake powell was
was built you know a lot of the issues
with lake mead
started after the advent of lake powell
so
would you agree that sort of the dam in
in lake powell
are are our clog in that colorado river
system
i i would say so and you know look the
the question today
isn't should we drain lake powell the
question today
is are we going to accept the reality
that lake powell is going away
and are we going to start taking steps
to better manage glen canyon
and the colorado river system around
glen canyon and lake mead that's that's
the reality
uh as you mentioned lake mead is about
to hit its lowest point in history
in the next year lake powell is going to
reach its lowest point since it began
filling in the 1960s
and while it sounds shocking none of
this came as a surprise to us or any of
the other people working on the colorado
river
this has been predict projected for
over 10 years i mean scientists and you
know academics
policy people who are paying attention
um
we've all been predicting this moment
for a long time and now that it's
finally here
we're saying you know it's really time
to take a hard look at how these
reservoirs are managed
and really assess uh this idea of moving
that water downstream because
the purpose of glen canyon dam is to
store
excess water for the upper basin states
but now that we don't have any excess
water in the system uh
it doesn't make sense to hang on to this
dwindling reservoir
we can move that upper basin water put
it in lake mead
and just count it for the upper basin
it's an accounting issue
one of the things that we hear a lot
about in terms
of the water going into lake mead is
obviously snowpack
and and and you know
drought and precipitation and all that
stuff but
if you could talk about how lake powell
is drying up not just because of the
release of water
um but also evaporation
and the difference in i believe there's
a difference in rocks that plays an
issue
here yeah so um you know
reservoirs by their nature are
inefficient they lose water to
uh evaporation surface evaporation they
lose water to seepage
and when you look at lake powell versus
lake mead it turns out that lake powell
is a less efficient reservoir so the
best data that's out now
suggests that if you were to combine the
storage in lake mead and fill me
first you would increase the system
efficiency a bit
you would reduce some of that surface
area you'd uh you would reduce
the surface evaporation and you'd reduce
seepage so the best numbers that we have
right now suggest that
filmed first could save anywhere from 30
000
fifty thousand acre feet a year
and the is there any data to show how
much
we're losing from evaporation it's a
very
tricky number to calculate um the the
figures for evaporation loss at lake
powell
haven't been updated since the 1970s so
we don't have great data on that
um and like me the the numbers are
a little they're more updated um i don't
know the exact figure but
the the rough uh calculation that that
water managers use is that when powell
and mead are full they lose about
um a million acre feet uh to evaporation
every year when they're full and when
they're half full or less
you could project that it's about half
that amount or less right
right so with this plan if if we're
talking about
water going down the down river to
nevada
which would then better
um you know which would better affect
nevada and california
versus utah and arizona what is the
is there any pushback from from those
upper
states absolutely there is push back
against this idea
um and it's it's sort of this symbolic
line right the
glen canyon dam is the dividing line of
the upper basin and the lower basin
and uh when when the water's released
downstream right now
that's sort of the delivery point of the
upper basin delivering its water to the
lower basin
so this idea of the upper basin states
storing water downstream in lake mead
well physically it's very easy to uh
conceive of there's a big political uh
boundary there
that's hard for policymakers to wrap
their heads around
so if the upper basin were to store
water in the in lake mead
it would need to be a protected pool if
you will that's kind of the
the way that it's talked about um it
would it would be looked at as a kind of
intentionally created surplus
in lake mead that counts as upper basin
delivered water
uh because for all intents and purposes
lake powell
is already a lower basin reservoir right
by the time the water gets there
none of the upper basin states can use
it anyway so
effectively it's already downstream so
it's again it's an accounting issue
of how do you put that water down there
and then count it for the upper basin
states
um so they're given credit for that
water right right um
when you talk to those policy leaders
you know both
in in upper basin and lower base and
what's their
what's their reaction to this idea
um it's it's outside of the box enough
that they're
i i don't think policymakers are ready
to entertain this idea
seriously but the scientists and some of
the people that are
tasked with studying management of the
river they are starting to look at it
seriously
and the reason we're starting to look at
it seriously is because i don't have a
choice
and i think that's the reality of this
conversation is that
at a certain point it just won't make
sense to
hang on to lake powell anymore it'll
make more sense to put that water down
in lake mead
and the question is what is the
elevation of powell and need
uh where it makes most sense for policy
makers so right now the bureau of
reclamation is projecting that
by next year lake powell could get down
to within
uh 3 525 feet which is
near the lower uh elevation balancing
tier
and that's just a stone's throw away
from the minimum power pool
so minimum power pool once once lake
powell goes below that level
glen canyon dam is no longer generating
electricity
and um we i mean lake powell reaching
minimum power pool within the next few
years is very much within the realm of
possibility
and once it goes below that level it
becomes a lot harder to manage
the reservoir and the you know the kind
of benefits of having the reservoir at
all really start to go away
and at that point it really starts to
make sense to look at the full draining
of lake powell
and putting the water in lake mead and
at that point
you just you keep the dam in place you
use glen canyon dam
as a backup reservoir if wetter
conditions return
what would happen in terms of power
generation
if if that happened uh once
once lake powell goes below minimum
power pool there is no power generation
at the res
glen canyon damn so that obviously
creates a lot of challenges
it wouldn't just it wouldn't stop uh it
wouldn't cause blackouts right
this wouldn't like destroy the
electrical grid there are many plenty of
other electrical sources on the grid
that could meet that demand
but it would be a big shift in where
some uh
you know suppliers electric suppliers
get electricity from
we actually had a study done a few years
ago to see what that impact would be to
ratepayers and if glen canyon damn were
to go offline
the average impact to end users so you
know people like you and me
would probably be an increase of eight
cents per month in the electrical bill
when you talk about this with with
stakeholders
in nevada whether it's politicians or
the bureau or or whoever or the you know
the reclamation
um what's
you know it it seems to it it seems
the argument seems to be well lake
powell should have never been
constructed and we should hold the water
in this other reservoir and this other
reservoir
that's only a third full um in in
in when you when you pitch that what's
the
i'm sure people into that will love it
but but what do they say to you like
let's get this going you know what's
what's the reaction
the the position of most stakeholders
right now is to not
rock the boat if it's not necessary so
you know at this point no major
stakeholders are saying let's go
fill me first but i think behind closed
doors more and more of them
are starting to seriously consider the
idea
um and you know in the upper basin we
live in a little bit of a different
reality
you know you guys down in las vegas have
taken some very serious
conservation measures california nevada
arizona
all those states are proactively
curtailing their use already
in the upper basin states uh you know
like utah for example
the state of utah right now is doing
everything it can
to build a new pipeline to suck new
water out of the colorado river
so while the lower basin states are
proactively planning
for drought the upper basin states are
trying to use more water
a lot of sprinklers going off there in
salt lake city
you know most of the water goes to
agriculture and that's that's the big
the big picture here but
um you know there's a lot of diversity
of interests when you're looking at
stakeholders in the colorado river basin
and our position is you know at a
certain point it's just not going to
make sense to hang on to lake powell
anymore
and meanwhile glen canyon which is this
incredible place right it's it was as
beautiful as the grand canyon it's
geographically it's sandwiched between
canyonlands national park
and grand canyon national park it's got
bears ears national monument to the
east and grand staircase national
monument to the west
glen canyon is the heart and soul of the
colorado river
and so much of it is coming back to life
almost a hundred thousand
acres of land are now out of water we
have
over you know hundreds of miles of newly
flowing rivers tributaries creeks
streams we're seeing waterfalls come
back
we're seeing arches come back natural
bridges
the wildlife is returning the plant life
is returning
there is a massive ecological
restoration happening in glen canyon
right now
and that needs to be taken into account
when we're talking about how to manage
the colorado river
one thing that um we talk about a lot
about lake mead
is the lower it gets the worse it gets
for
recreation and tourism and and you know
there are towns along like need
that rely on voting and recreation and
stuff like that and of how to evolve
because the water isn't there anymore is
it sort of the reverse
at lake powell i mean i i assume there
has to be some sort of recreation on the
on the lake that that people wouldn't
want it to get any lower or am i wrong
no that's right uh you know there's
there's still a lot of reservoir
recreation
going on at lake powell and you know i
i'm not
trying to you know look down on people
who like to do that because
i have family and friends you know i'm a
i'm a utah guy and
people love lake powell and i totally
understand it but as this reservoir
draws down
as a result of this supply and demand
imbalance
the recreation that's going to be
happening in the canyon is going to
transition to more back country
or national park style recreation
if and when uh lake powell fully goes
away
uh the the recreation there would
resemble something more like
a national park like uh zion and utah or
canyonlands national park
uh where you have you know river rafting
backpacking hiking
um some of the you know kind of like you
see uh around paige arizona
with the overlook or the antelope canyon
uh hiking tours uh
you know the recreation picture is gonna
change a lot
whether or not people want it to right
right but also
you're you're saying that by going back
to the original
sort of landscape that's a whole that's
sort of
an even better way to recreate and draws
people in
oh yeah i mean the the restoration
happening in glen canyon is gonna
is gonna be it collectively it would be
the biggest
river restoration site in the world and
there's
there's nowhere else like it and we're
already seeing it happen on the main
stem of the colorado river
as it enters what used to be lake powell
there's now 40 miles
of free-flowing colorado river so we're
seeing white water rapids come back
we're seeing the sediment get washed
away up there um
you know it's a completely evolving
resource and it's
it's a very important resource to uh
river runners and
and backpackers and just a different set
of recreationists
right so i'll lastly i'll ask you sort
of
what i what i asked you at the beginning
and
i i see the picture behind you and
you know when you sort of look at lake
powell it doesn't really look like a
lake it looks like
you know a snake on top of another snake
that they decided to clog
up and you know build a river build a
reservoir it doesn't really look like a
reservoir
is you know you had mentioned that
this was a flawed project from the
beginning can you talk about
um what makes it
flawed you know is it is it something
into the
in the design is it something and and
how it and how it functions you know
what
what makes this bad when glen canyon dam
was commissioned in 1956
there were no environmental laws in the
united states
there was no endangered species act
there was no nepa
there were no studies that had to be
done there was no assessment of what the
impact to the environment would be um it
wasn't part of the
american ethos yet right it was after a
glen canyon dam
was built is when the modern
environmental movement really started in
the u.s so
nobody looked at glen canyon and and
asked the question of what would be the
impact to the
native fish species what would be the
impact to the wildlife
um and and more broadly is it worth it
to drown
you know one of the most incredible
canyons in the world
you got to remember at that time the
bureau of reclamation wanted to build
dams in the grand canyon
and if you propose that today people
would laugh at your face because the
grand canyon is such an
important resource as a free-flowing
river in a canyon
and the same should be said for glen
canyon upstream right
um it was just not something that was
looked at when the dam was built
originally
but is there something about its design
or i always thought you know what when i
got
people like oh lake powell evaporates
and and it's a huge
issue and you know i sort of look at the
picture behind you and it's like oh
because the surface area is sort of all
over the place
am i completely wrong in thinking that
that has anything to do with it because
i thought i was super smart
uh no you're not wrong i mean look
all dams are flawed all dams are
temporary
um all dams will eventually fill up with
sediment
the colorado river is one of the most
sediment filled rivers and
um depending on who you ask you know
that reservoir behind me would fill up
with sediment regardless of its drawdown
so
um all all dams and reservoirs have
their own flaws but
um i think the biggest flaw of glen
canyon dam is that it drowned one of the
most amazing places on the planet
all right anything else i didn't ask you
um
well i just can't emphasize enough the
ecological
rebound that's happening in this canyon
it's truly amazing
if you ever want to go see it i'd be
happy to take you out there and
show you some of the waterfalls and
arches that are coming back and see the
wildlife and plant life